hunting for Easter eggs and movies has
become a passion for large numbers of
movie geeks out there in fact there's no
shortage of YouTube channels whose whole
deal is all about pointing out Easter
eggs you might have missed in movies or
even just their trailers movie sites and
wiki's abound with lists of Easter eggs
to be found in your favorite flicks and
yet even with all that there are some
Easter eggs from classic movies that
don't appear on any site or YouTube
video for some reason in fact once we
point them out to you you'll wonder how
you miss these amazing Easter eggs for
so so long here's a whole basket of
movie easter eggs that no one has ever
thought to point out until now malls
attract strange company the 1995 follow
up to Kevin Smith's seminal cult tum
clerks Mallrats boasts any number of
unforgettable scenes like the one where
a bearded Stanley pops up to talk about
Ben Grimm's junk or the one with a
schooner and the magic eye Wow or the
one where Michael Rooker currently
beloved for his roles in The Walking
Dead and guardians of the galaxy licks
butt juice off his hand but for true
center files who are always looking to
trump each other by uncovering the
coolest and most obscure Easter eggs and
movies one scene in particular stands
out early in the film the lovable
slacker Brody gets dumped by his
girlfriend Renee to date Ben Affleck's
character Affleck then kidnaps Brody and
beats him up but when Brody's friends
including Jay and Silent Bob ask him
what happened he lies and says the malls
Easter Bunny is the one who busted his
nose all I said was Easter Bunny at the
Menlo Park mall was more convincing he
just jumps aurelion knocked me down Jay
and Silent Bob decide to avenge their
pal Brody in the way they know best
tactless violence but eagle-eyed viewers
will catch an added layer to this scene
if you look in the background you'll see
several plastic Easter bunnies holding
baskets and what's in those baskets yeah
boy it's Easter Egg
Bill & Ted's bogus holiday Bill & Ted's
bogus journey is the vastly
underappreciated 1991 sequel to 1989's
Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure a movie
that somehow managed to both kick off
Keanu Reeves career and end Alex winters
while the original film is about Bill
and Ted travelling through time to
gather historical figures in order to
pass their history presentation bogus
journey focuses on the two teens getting
killed by evil robot versions of
themselves going to hell and teaming up
with the Grim Reaper to save their
fiance's it rules while in hell the
dudes are forced to face their greatest
fears which include bills grody
grandmother and a military school curdle
who assigns them infinite push-ups the
scariest vision of all however is one in
which Ted is reverted to a younger
version of himself who had stolen a
basket full of candy with his younger
brothers name on it as he digs into the
basket he's confronted by a Chucky faced
pink rabbit who chases and taunts him
for making his brother cry
yep the basket Ted stole from his
brother was an Easter basket in other
words you guessed it it was totally
loaded with delicious Easter eggs
guardians of the galaxy 2012's rise of
the guardians is an incredibly rad
animated film about the guardians of
childhood a secret society of magical
figures who help protect children and
fight to keep childhood magical for them
members of the team include Santa Claus
the Tooth Fairy the Sandman Jack Frost
and a mysterious fellow named e aster
bunny meant to make a long story short
it turns out that this name is actually
a cleverly hidden reference to the
Easter Bunny which would totally explain
some of Bunnymen's characteristics like
you know the fact that he's a large
talking bunny
obsessed with Easter it also gives a new
significance to the swarms of seemingly
sentient mobile eggs that follow him
around what you know bunny Minh is
actually the Easter Bunny you might
start to realize that these aren't the
normal everyday walking colored eggs
that you see all the time
these are actually Easter eggs cool
right
and all it took to figure it out was a
little word puzzle-solving
definitely makes all that time spent
doing word searches feel like it was
worth it if you're not a kangaroo what
are you I'm a bunny
the Easter Bunny nightmare before Easter
this next scene only makes sense thanks
to fan theories from the internet but if
those theories are right it makes for a
cool and unexpected easter egg The
Nightmare Before Christmas is a 1993
stop-motion animated movie where every
major holiday has its own town devoted
to the celebration of that holiday Jack
Skellington the pumpkin king of
Halloween town accidentally stumbles
across a portal to Christmas town and
becomes obsessed with it he decides
Halloween town will run Christmas this
year and so he sends his minions locked
shock and Barrel to kidnap Santa Claus
why so Jack and do up the Yuletide in
his own stripy Tim Burton Hot Topic
fever dream aesthetic that year this
trick-or-treating trio doesn't initially
come back with Santa Claus however
instead they bring back a roughly human
sized rabbit carrying a basket and
wearing a sash that says Happy Easter on
it now here's where that cool fan theory
kick said since each of the portals
leads to a different holiday one of
those doors might just lead to some kind
of Easter town we know get out those
crime boards people that would mean that
this man-sized basket toting rabbit is
actually the Easter Bunny and those
lumps in his basket are probably those
tasty Easter eggs we've been hunting
that is if the fan theory is true the
big picture Universal Pictures has been
using an image of the planet Earth with
some version of its name superimposed on
it since the beginning of its existence
even if it has evolved a bit in the
studio's century plus history one thing
has been consistent however it's always
the logo on top of our regular old brown
globe earth or is it
[Music]
hop is a 2011 film from Universal that
finally makes a movie out of the old
traditional story we've all known and
loved since childhood that the Easter
Bunny has a son who would rather play
drums in a rock and roll music band and
deliver Easter baskets
and whose Dukes are actually jelly beans
the genius behind the hit and Easter egg
and hop is that it comes before the
movie even starts take a gander at the
flicks first few seconds that familiar
Universal globe isn't quite how you
remember is it it isn't round and now it
isn't flat either it's kind of oval you
might even call it egg-shaped the Easter
Bunny is coming to town these days
rankin/bass productions is perhaps best
known for its christmas specials like
Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer Frosty
the Snowman and Santa Claus is coming to
town but they actually produced a large
number of non Christmas specials between
1964 and 1987 including a series of
three separate origin films for the
Easter Bunny in a span of six years the
last of these three Easter Bunny
specials was 1977's the Easter Bunny is
coming to town as the film's name
implies it's a sequel to 1970s Santa
Claus is coming to town and it actually
follows the template set out by that
previous film maybe a little too closely
filling the role of the winter warlock
from Santa Claus is a grumpy bear named
gadzooks who has a tendency to steal
anything holiday related that anyone
tries to carry past his home on Big Rock
Mountain in one scene the future Easter
Bunny named Sonny just like James Caan's
character in The Godfather tries to
cross the mountain only to be accosted
by get zukes when gadzooks inspects
Sonny's basket looking for snacks he
finds the basket is full of colored
stones that Sonny intends to sell as
paperweights a close viewing of the film
however will call to mind an earlier
scene in which Sonny and his friends
actually painted a large number of eggs
bright colors in order to specifically
fool gadzooks
so not only does this scene feature some
cool Easter eggs it actually reveals the
true
totally 100% historically accurate
origin of Easter eggs not too shabby
who
hard-boiled Roger Rabbit 1988 to Framed
Roger Rabbit is the most ambitious
crossover event in history no matter
what Marvel Studios says where else can
you see Mickey Mouse Bugs Bunny Woody
Woodpecker droopy and Pinocchio in one
movie anyway one scene in particular
stands out to fans scouring this
reference Laden flick for Easter eggs in
the scene human detective Eddie valiant
is haunted by an egg peeling barfly for
working on a job with a toon
Eddie angrily shoves the egg in the
louts mouth before we learned that
Eddie's long-standing anti toon
prejudice comes from the fact that
children killed his brother it may seem
like a stretch but could this regular
egg actually fee an easter egg hear us
out Disney is known for its
perfectionism and its animated films are
filled with Easter eggs so it's unlikely
that such a noticeable choice would be
meaningless so a prominent inclusion of
an egg in a movie that stars a rabbit
should be setting off some alarm bells
in your head egg plus rabbit sounds like
Disney thought they could slip an easter
egg past us without us noticing did we
forget something all right happy Easter
2018 and happy April Fool's Day too
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]